اهلا بكم من جديد الملف النووي الايراني
يعود للواجهه من جديد بعد جمود طويل وسط
شكوك ومخاوف اسرائيليه من التقدم الذي
تحرزه طهران في تخصيب اليورانيوم دفع
دبلوماسيه جديده بشان برنامج ايران نووي
ووساطه بين واشنطن وطهران جاءت عبر سلطنه
عمان هذا ما كشفته تقرير لصادر او تقرير
صادر عن موقع اكسوس الاخباري الذي تحدث عن
مساء وصفتها اسرائيل بالخفيه تبذلها اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن للتواصل مع
ايران بشان برنامج طهران نووي عبر وساطه
عمانيه ونقل الموقع عن مسؤولين امريكيين
واسرائيليين وحتى اوروبيين قولهم ان كبيره
مستشر الرئيس الامريكي سافر الى عمان
اوائل مايو لبحث حل دبلوماسي وبعثي
محادثات غير مباشره مع ايران التي تواصل
تكثيف وتيره انشطتها نوويه المسؤول
الاسرائيلي قال لموقع اك بان هذه
المحادثات غير المباشره التي اجرتها عمان
بين الولايات المتحده وايران باتت مصدر
قلق لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الذي يتخوف
من مساعي واشنطن التي يمكن ان تتكلم
بابرام اتفاق بمحتمل مع طهران التي ارسلت
من خلال هذه المحادثات غير العلنيه اشارات
واضحه لواشنطن مفادها الاستعداد لتقييد
البرنامج النووي وتهيئه الوضع الاقليمي
في المقابل نفى متحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي بالبيت الابيض مزاعم المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين قائلا لنو واشنطن لا تجري اي
مناقشات بخصوص ابرام اتفاق مؤقت مع ايران
وتخفيف العقوبات تصريحات سبقتها تاكيدات
من وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان في مقابله مع صحيفه لوفيجارو
ان بلاده اجرت محادثات غير رسميه مع
الولايات المتحده بشان برنامجها النووي
عبر وسطاء واشار الى انهم كانوا على وشك
التوصل لاتفاق لكن محاوريهم طالبوا
بالمزيد من الوقت خلال هذه المحادثات وهو
ما اعاق التقدم على حد تعبيره
الملف النووي الايراني
توقفت المحادثات بين ايران والدول الغربيه
والولايات المتحده لاحياء الاتفاق النووي
الموقعي عام 2015 بعد ان وصلت لفريق مسدود
بسبب تمسك كل من طهران وواشنطن بموقفيهما
فيما يخص تغيير بعض البنود الوارده في
الاتفاق وضمانات الالتزام به الولايات
المتحده انسحبت احاديا من الاتفاق عام
واعادت فرض عقوبات شديده على طهران
بدات اطراف الاتفاق بمشاركه غير مباشره من
الولايات المتحده مباحثات تهدف لاحيائه في
ابريل 2021
لكنها تعثرت اعتبارا من سبتمبر
ابريل الماضي اكسيوس الحكومه الامريكيه
ناقشت مع شركائها الاوروبيين
والاسرائيليين خطه اتفاق مؤقت مع ايران
لالغاء بعض العقوبات مقابل وقف اجزاء من
البرنامج النووي بما في ذلك تخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 60%
وللمزيد المتابعه انضم الى هنا من طهران
عبر سكايب مصدق بور الكاتب والاستاذ في
العلوم السياسيه ومن واشنطن
المستشار السابق في وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه اهلا بكما ضيفي العزيزين واسم
حالي ان ابدا مع ضيفي من طهران السيد مصدق
بور الكاتب والاستاذ في العلوم السياسيه
بدايه
في ظل اجواء المصالحه التي تعيشها المنطقه
هل يمكن القول بانه ايران بالفعل ارسلت
اشارات ايجابيه للولايات المتحده بانها
على استعداد للتفاوض وتقييد برنامجها
النووي واشاعه جو من الاستقرار في المنطقه
نعم تحياتي لكم لصديقنا السيد بولك
ولمشاهديكم
احنا لا اعتقد يعني اولا تحياتي الاجواء
الاقليميه من قبل ايران لا يمت الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الصله يعني
هذه هي السياسه ايرانيه ثابته كانت تدعو
لها من قبل ربما الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي من كانت تعرقل هذا المسار
ولا تسمح وتالب هذه الدول ضد ايران
باساليب مختلفه وبالتالي هذا الموضوع لا
نستطيع ان نجمع بين هذا الموضوع وبين
الموضوع النووي صحيح يعني الوضع الاقليمي
والعامل الاقليمي كان له دور كبير في
عرقله هذه المفاوضات ولكن اليوم ايران
شعرت بحاجه ماسه وضروريه لازاله هذا
الحاجز الاقليمي من خلال التقارب مع
شقيق المملكه العربيه السعوديه وسائر
الدول الجوار علما انها وجهت يعني في
الفترات السابقه ايضا دعوات
مشروع التعاون والتقارب بين
الخليج وبالتالي انا اعتقد يعني الموضوع
الامريكي منفصل عن الموضوع الاقليمي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اليوم هي تدعو
ايران وتقول وتريد ان تتحدث وكان تريد ان
تتحدث
بلغه الدبلوماسيه الحقيقه هذه الدبلوماسيه
التي تريدها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هي في الواقع يعني فرض املاءات وفرض ما
تريده على الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
نحن لدينا تجارب كثيره مع الولايات لكن
اسمح لها مقاطعه وزير الخارجيه قال بانه
بلاده اقر انه بلاده اجرت محادثات غير
مباشره مع واشنطن وكانت قاده قوسين او
ادنى من التوصل لاتفاق وبالتالي هذا ينسجم
مع ما ذكرته
نعم انا انا اقول يعني ايران ابدت حسن
النوايا في الفتاه السابق يعني الموضوع
احتجاز رهائن منذ عام 1981 كان لدينا ايضا
ارتفاع في الجزائر مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبموجب ذلك الاتفاق سعاده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بين رفع
العقوبات عن ايران وفك تجميد عن الاصول
الايرانيه التي المجمده في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من عهد الشهر السابق
ولكن ماذا حدث نحن في المقابل قمنا
بالتزاماتنا واطلقنا صراحه رعائن
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين الذين احتجزوا في
طهران جيد
برايك يعني ما الاسباب التي قد تدفع
واشنطن مثلا
لكي لا تعلن ان هناك وساطه عمانيه بين
طهران
و واشنطن
سؤال جيد الجواب بصراحه كامل غير واضح بس
انا شخصيا انا اقيم انه
هذا ليس من جديد المعنى انه كان هناك
مفاوضات غير رسميه غير عالميه غير مباشره
بين واشنطن وطيران من زمان في اماكن
مختلفه في العالم في
ديانه في واشنطن في عمان في في العراق في
ربما في اماكن اخرى في المنطقه وخارج
المنطقه وهذا كما انا ما قلت ليس من جديد
والنوايا الامريكيه
ان ربما
تختفي هذه المفاوضات حتى
لاحظوا اللحظه الاخيره من اجل
مكاسبه اتفاق في نهايه الامر المعنى انه
التسريبات
والاشاعات
والتركز الاعلامي هو السؤال هنا انه بما
انه الولايات المتحده هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي تجري فيها مفاوضات سريه وغير
مباشره لماذا لا تعلنها ما الذي تخشاه
بالضبط
[ضحك]
الجمله السبب الرئيسي لهذا التصرف السري
او شبه سري انه
المخاوف في واشنطن بالنسبه
للتسريبات التي ربما تضرر
المفاوضات وتعرقل احتمال مكاسبه اتفاق في
نهايه الامر
بسبب
المخاوف والشكوك او شكوات الاسرائيليه على
سبيل المثال بسبب
ربما
خلافات الداخليه هنا في واشنطن بين بعض
الخبراء وبعد حتى بعد المسؤولين الامريكان
داخل الاداره او بين
الشيوخ
والنواب في الكونجرس الامريكي من الحزباء
اثنين اتجاه الاتفاق مع ايران وكذا وكذا
المعنى انه نحن بشكل عام نحن الامريكان
نحن نفضل
اسرار على
تصريحات
والشفافيه وضعنا دعنا نرى ضيفي من طهران
هل تفضل ايران الصراحه
تفضل اسرار ايضا هل يمكن القول بان هناك
بالفعل محادثات تتم بين ايران والولايات
المتحده عبر الوسيط العماني واذا كان
الامر كذلك هل تعتقد بانه يعني طهران
تعتقد بان عمان ربما وسيط اكثر
نزاهه من الوسيط الاوروبي الذي لم ينجح في
محادثات فيينا على مدى اشهر طويله باحداث
خرق في الجمود الذي طال في هذا الملف
طبعا الوسيط العماني ويختلف عن الوسيط
الاوروبي الوسيط الاوروبي هو جزء من
المشكله وليس جزء من الحل ولكن الوسيط
الالماني هو العماني العماني هو جزء من
الحل بالتالي لن تفضل هذا الوسيط اما
الموضوع الاخر الذي سالتني بخصوصه فيما
يتعلق بالسريه او ان تفضل بعدم تسريب مثل
هذه المعلومات ايران تختلف عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي في الداخل لا تواجه
يعني مشاكل كثيره ربما هناك اجماع بين
التيارات المختلفه حول ضروره التفاوض
والضروره انهاء الازمه النوويه بالحل
السلمي ولكن ربما هناك فوارق وهناك
اختلافات حول
الكيفيه وكيفيه وسرعه انجاز هذا المشروع
يعني هناك من ينظر الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بتشاؤم وعدم ثقه وبالتالي
ويحاول يعني ان يتحفظ كثيرا ويحاول ان
يضمن يعني ضمانات ويضمن مصالح ويضم
اجتماعيه حتى ياخذ هذه المفاوضات فهناك من
يصدق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كما حدث
في
الحكومه السابقه التي هي اولت تماما على
جانب الاوروبي وعلى جانب الامريكي وصدقتهم
وبالتالي مضت معهم في هذا المشروع ولكن
ايران يعني بموجب الاتفاق في
ايران ادت التزاماتها هي خفضت التخصيب
خفضت لكن يعني وانت تتحدث عن يعني
الالتزامات
التقليل الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
يعني يقول لا ادري اذا كان لدي يقول بانه
ايران تواصل انتهاك القيود المفروض على
برنامجها النووي وانا اقتبس هنا وانه
مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم يتجاوز 23 مره
الحد المسموح به وبالتالي كيف يمكن اعتبار
ان ايران التزم ت
بتعليمات الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اسرائيل
تخشى من هذه المحادثات فما هو وجه الخوف
يعني اذا كانت هذه المحادثات قد تفضي الى
اتفاق يمنع ايران من الاستمرار بالمضي
قدما في هذا البرنامج ويمنعها من تطوير
قنبله نوويه لماذا تخشى اسرائيل اي محادثه
سواء كانت معلنه او غير معلنه بين واشنطن
وطهران
سؤال جيد انا شخصيا انا اقيم من بعيد انه
المخاوف الاسرائيليه صحيحه لان
الحقيقه انه نحن كنا نرى برامج ايرانيه
عسكريه نوعيه سريه ما يخالف من زمان من
تقريبا عشرين سنه او اكثر من ذلك
وما يخالف الالتزامات والاتفاقيات
التصريحات الرسميه الايرانيه لذلك انا
اعتقد انه
التنسيق الامريكي الاسرائيلي والامريكي
العربي وحتى الاسرائيلي والعربي بالنسبه
لهذا الملف ضروري
لازدياد او تشجيع تعزيز الثقه بين
القوات تلك القوات
لان ليس هناك للاسف الشديد ثقه بين ايران
وامريكا كما قال الزميل المحترم بشكل عام
او بين طبعا ايران واسرائيل وحتى بين
ايران والعرب على الرغم من التقارب في
الفتره الاخيره في الملفات الدبلوماسيه مع
السعوديه ومع بلدان عربيه اخرى لذلك
الحقيقه انه نحن سوف نرى في الاسبوع
القادم
زياره
رسميه اسرائيليه في اعلى مستوى بين
[موسيقى]
الماسولين الامريكان هنا في واشنطن
والمستشار الاعلى للامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ووزير الشؤون الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيلي
بنسبه لهذه المفاوضات
سيد مصدق
امريكا اوضحت اكثر من مره بانه موضوع يعني
التوجه نحو انتاج قنبله نوويه امر لا يمكن
السماح به لكن ايران او اسرائيل اعتبرت ان
ذلك خط احمر وقامت بمهاجمه البرنامج
النووي مرات عده الا تخشى ايران من ان
تقدم اسرائيل على ربما هجوم اكبر اذا ما
شعرت بان ايران ماضيه وان هذه المحادثات
كلها لا تصل الى الامر المرغوب وهو وقف
هذا البرنامج النووي الذي تخشاه اسرائيل
بالدرجه الاولى في المنطقه
طبعا قال صديقي يقول لك بان ايران يعني
منذ سنوات طويله هي تريد ان تنتج القنبله
النوويه اذا لماذا لم تنتج يعني دائما
كانوا يحددون اراد ويحددون مؤهل ويعطون
لانفسهم مولى ويقولون ان ايران بعد 60
يوما بعد شهرين بعد ثلاثه اشهر وتمضي
السنين
طويله دون ان تلجا ايران الى تصنيع
القنبله النوويه اذا ايران ليست لديها نيه
بانتاج القنبله النوويه ولا ترى ان قدرتها
ومشروعيتها تكتسب من هذه القنبله النوويه
يعني ايراني تحارب اليوم بمنطق بقوه
المنطق ولا تريد ان تحارب بمنطقه القوه
ايران يعني لديها اسلوب خاص لديها اسلوب
سياسي اما الجانب الاسرائيلي هو ايضا يعني
انا اعتقد يعني هناك تبادل الادوار بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل يعني
هم الامريكيين اليوم يقولون بان اسرائيل
هي الحاجز تعددنا من جهه اخرى وبالتالي
يريدون ان ينتزعوا التنازلات وتراجعات من
الجانب الايراني والجانب الايراني يعني
هذا الموضوع يعني اساسا من السذاجه ان
نفكر ان هناك
انفكاك وهناك تباعد او هناك اي خلاف بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سواء الحمائم
والسواء والصقور الجمهوريه الديمقراطيين
الكل مجمعون على دعم هذا الكيان يعتبر هذا
الكيان ويعمل على حفظ مصالحهم وان كان لا
يعمل الان على حفظ مصالح هؤلاء وتحول الى
عباء الى عباء شكرا سياسات الامريكيه في
هذه المنطقه انا اعتقد يعني هذه تبادل
يعني اعتذر منك انتهى وقتي تماما اعطيتك
فرصه لتتحدث سيد مصدق بور الكاتب والاستاذ
كنت معنا من طهران وايضا الشكر موصول
لضيفي ديفيد بولوك المستشار في السابق في
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه كان معنا من
واشنطن شكرا لكم مشاهدينا ايضا على متابعه
بانوراما الى اللقاء غدا بحول الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصه الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات